innerhalb kürzester zeit ist der
datenverkehr im internet regelrecht
explodiert das haben forscher jetzt auch
am größten internet knotenpunkt der welt
dem de-cix in frankfurt festgestellt bei
bestimmten daten sind es 120
egal ob home office oder homeschooling
das internet ist durch die korona
pandemie noch unabdingbar geworden als
es bereits vorher war ein echter
stresstest und in deutschland zeigt sich
jetzt wie schlecht wir darauf
vorbereitet sind pixum science im future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannendes
seines videos abonniert den kanal und
aktive die glocken nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
der redaktion von ix entstanden das
fachmagazin informiert über alle
wegweisenden entwicklungen im it bereich
und am ende oder hierunter me und in der
video beschreibung könnt ihr euch eine
digitale ausgabe gratis sichern
keine frage die korona pandemie ist für
die gesamte welt ganz neu auch für das
internet wir schreiben mehr e-mails
arbeiten von zu hause aus shoppen online
und verbringen auch mehr zeit mit
streaming und so ist klar der
datenverkehr im internet hat sich enorm
verändert und wenn wir mal ehrlich sind
macht das internet vielen von uns sehr
viel möglich dazu oliver hohlfeld von
der brandenburgischen technischen
universität kurzen btu cottbus
senftenberg nur das internet hat es uns
ermöglicht unser leben während der
pandemie so fortzuführen das internet
und corona sind eine erfolgsgeschichte
doch ist das wirklich so und was macht
der enormen datenverkehr mit dem
internet was passiert mit dem netz der
netze wenn plötzlich die ganze welt ihr
verhalten ändert kann das internet dem
lockdown trotzen die große sorge stand
im raum dass die immense belastung zu
ausfällen und zahlreichen störungen
führt ein internationales forschungsteam
um oliver hohlfeld hat genau diese
fragen genauer ins visier genommen dazu
haben die forschenden die veränderung
bei einem großen europäischen provider
mit rund 15 millionen festnetzkunden
sowie zwei großen europäischen
internetknoten analysiert konkret wurde
der zeitraum vom januar bis juni 2020
und der datenverkehr unter anderem an
internetknoten in zentral- und südeuropa
sowie an der us-ostküste gemessen
die ergebnisse sind eindeutig laut der
studie ist der durchschnittliche in
verkehr weltweit zu beginn des ersten
block downs im märz des vergangenen
jahres 2020 um 15 bis 30 prozent
angestiegen eine riesige menge also und
das innerhalb weniger tage um das zu
verdeutlichen das entspricht der
steigerung von der provider pro jahr
ausgehen ein konkretes beispiel dafür
beim de cix in frankfurt war der pick
traffic um 27 prozent angestiegen einer
rekord steigerung im jahresvergleich in
der gesamten geschichte des de-cix er
die six also der deutsche commercial
internet exchange gilt als größter
internet-knoten der welt gemessen am
datendurchsatz ein weiteres ergebnis der
aktuellen analyse die korona pandemie
und die damit verbundenen lockdown
führen auch zu einer veränderung der
hauptnutzungszeit des internets vor
corona wurde das internet in der woche
hauptsächlich in den abendstunden
genutzt dann also wenn die leute von der
schule vom studium oder job nach hause
kam
die last spitze lag dann meist so gegen
20 uhr abends eben dann wenn alle
netflix und so weiter schauen seit
beginn des ersten aktes im märz 2020
aber wird das internet gleichmäßig über
den gesamten tag verteilt genutzt vor
allem der datenverkehr durch
videokonferenzen ist enorm in die höhe
gestiegen am de cix gab es einen zuwachs
in diesem bereich von achtung 120 doch
nicht nur beruflich sondern auch privat
läuft die kommunikation der menschen
während der korona krise verstärkt über
online dienste und auch die nutzung von
social media ist enorm in die höhe
gestiegen
so konnten marktforschungsunternehmen
mit hilfe von umfragen in 17 ländern
zeigen dass vor allem junge
internetnutzer zwischen 16 und 24 jahren
social media in der korona krise
vermehrt nutzen aber nicht nur das auch
in der gruppe mit dem schwächsten
wachstum nämlich bei den menschen
zwischen 55 und 64 jahren nutzt fast
jeder dritte während der korona pandemie
häufiger social media auch das online
shopping boomt nicht nur mehr kleidung
wird online gekauft sondern mittlerweile
auch vermehrt lebensmittel und
haushaltswaren umfragen zufolge konnten
supermärkte zum teil dreimal so hohe
zugriffszahlen verzeichnen als vor der
korona pandemie doch wie hat das
internet diesen stresstest bislang
weggesteckt und welche
kapazitätsreserven hat es noch könnte es
bei weiteren lebens noch einmal so enorm
hohe zuwachsraten wegstecken laut der
studie bei der unter anderem auch
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
von der btu kopf
senftenberg und des max planck instituts
für informatik beteiligt waren waren die
internet infrastrukturen den höheren
belastungen zu jeder zeit gewachsen ein
grund dafür sehen die fachleute vor
allem auch darin dass die lastspitzen
stark über den tag verteilt sind auch
wenn das internet also deutlich mehr
genutzt wird als vor dem ersten showdown
im märz 2020 passiert dies eben über
viele stunden verteilt so konnten die
internet infrastrukturen den höheren
belastung also zuverlässig trotzen dazu
oliver hohlfeld von der btu cottbus
senftenberg in einem interview mit rbb
24 wir sehen also es ist eine sehr
flexible infrastruktur wir haben große
fortschritte in der technologisierung
also im schalten von neuen kapazitäten
das verdanken wir der vielen forschungen
ins internet und dem hohen technischen
fortschritt bei den providern die
auswirkungen des um 15 bis 30 prozent
gestiegen und aufkommenden konnten wohl
durch zwei faktoren so gut abgefangen
werden zum einen durch die vorhandene
reservekapazität gemeint ist damit der
netzausbau der vor beginn der pandemie
durchgeführt wurde
zum anderen fand auch eine schnelle
schaltung zusätzlicher kapazitäten stadt
also ein neuer netzausbau so konnte das
internationale forschungsteam beobachten
dass zusätzliche bandbreite in vielen
netzen geschaltet werden konnte im
klartext offenbart dass auch dass eine
schnelle reaktion auf veränderte
bedingungen enorm wichtig ist ebenso wie
das vorhalten von reservekapazität
dennoch zu engpässen kann es immer kommt
doch das ist der aktuellen studie
zufolge dann eher eine frage von lokalen
uhr sahen als beispiel wird hier unter
anderem der verbesserungswürdige
breitbandausbau in vielen regionen
genannt online vorlesungen für
studierende sind dann beispielsweise
nicht mehr möglich auch engpässe auf
manchen verbindungsleitung zwischen
netzen oder anschlüssen von firmen sind
nicht auszuschließen doch das sind
punktuelle dinge die in ihrem ursprung
nichts mit der korona pandemie zu tun
haben dennoch deckte corona pandemie
erneut auf was sache ist in den
ballungsgebieten muss kaum jemand auf
eine schnelle internetleitung verzichten
der breitbandausbau in einigen
ländlichen regionen dagegen lässt zu
wünschen übrig ein krasses
stadt-land-gefälle offenbart
beispielsweise der aktuelle
breitbandatlas für sachsen vor allem im
landkreis nordsachsen wird enormer
nachholbedarf sichtbar
das muss man sich mal vorstellen in der
gemeinde reinhardtsdorf-schöna in der
sächsischen schweiz haben nur zwei der
halter eine leitung mit 16 mbit und das
ist ja nach heutigen maßstäben ja
wirklich nicht schnell hier sind größere
up oder download einfach nicht möglich
geschweige denn videostreams schon vor
der korona pandemie gab es für die
menschen in solchen regionen also
spürbare nachteile natürlich auch im
bereich wirtschaft denn neue firmen
siedeln sich eben nicht dort an wo es
nur langsames internet gibt doch die
fehlende bandbreite macht jetzt auch den
unternehmen zu schaffen deren
angestellten im home office in diesen
regionen unter solchen schlechten netz
bedingungen arbeiten sollen der
bürgermeister des sächsischen waldenburg
bernd pohlers sagt dazu wir machen hier
keine home office wir können in der
verwaltung fast allen mitarbeitern ein
einzelzimmer anbieten
unser internet hier in waldenburg ist
noch nicht in allen bereichen auf dem
standard dass man das in allen
ortsteilen umsetzen könnte
die korona krise offenbart also
schonungslos dass die digitalisierung an
vielen stellen bislang nicht
ernstgenommen wurde
der bundesverband digitale wirtschaft
bvdw war bereits im vergangenen sommer
2020 zu dem schluss gekommen dass hier
dringender handlungsbedarf besteht der
staat habe dafür zu sorgen
zitat dass ein flächendeckender 5g
ausbau schnelles internet überall
ermöglicht deutschland gehört der welt
war zu den schlusslichtern auf
weltweiter ebene dagegen fällt das fazit
des internationalen forschungsteams im
großen und ganzen positiv aus nach
ansicht der fachleute sind sogar weitere
kapazitätsreserven am stab selbst wenn
weitere menschen ins home office
geschickt würden befürchten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
keinerlei probleme
dazu oliver hoffeld er ist inhaber des
lehrstuhls rechnernetze und
kommunikationssysteme an der btu
kompetenzen berg die flexibilität ist da
das internet verbringt hier wirklich
wundervolles wir sollten das allerdings
nicht als gegeben hinnehmen wir brauchen
immer neue forschung um den
technologischen fortschritt weiter zu
bringen so dass solche sachen einfach
funktionieren mehr zum thema und anderen
umfassend recherchierten dem aus dem
it-bereich erfahrt ihr im fachmagazin ix
von it security über big data bis hin zu
embedded systems exklusiv für euch klick
zum zuschauen de gibt es jetzt eine
digitale ausgabe gratis kriegt dafür
einfach auf diesen link oder unten in
die video beschreibung also anklicken
anschauen und dann das gratis
herunterladen bis dann
bleibt dann